voilà priorité à l'actualité nous
retournons à lyon car à l'instant on
connaît le verdict dans le procès de
patrick dils
dominique verdeilhan patrick dils et
acquittés par les jurés du rhône oui et
vous entendez probablement david pujadas
derrière moi les applaudissements les
mêmes applaudissements qui ont rententi
il y à peine cinq minutes dans la salle
de la cour d'assises lorsqu'il a fallu
attendre la cinquième question et
lorsqu'à la cinquième question la
réponse fut non cela veut dire donc que
patrick dils est acquitté ça veut dire
qu'il est reconnue donc innocent de ce
crime pour lequel il avait été
précédemment condamné par deux fois
normalement donc patrick dils va être
libéré dans l'eure où leurs ennemis qui
vient depuis la prison saint paul où il
était incarcéré pendant la durée de son
procès ensuite il y aura pour lui un
autre combat qui sera celui de
l'indemnisation après ses 15 ans de
prison
15 ans de prison est aujourd'hui un
acquittement alors vous restez avec nous
dominique car évidemment c'est un coup
de semonce pour la justice